-Our first guest tonight is
a United States Senator
from Vermont.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Senator
Bernie Sanders, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Senator, it's always a pleasure
to have you here.
-Great to be with you.
-We've talked a lot over Zoom
the last three years,
but it's been three years
since I've seen you in person.
It makes a big difference,
so I appreciate
you making the effort.
-My pleasure.
-I promise we're gonna
get to the serious stuff,
but I do enjoy talking
about how, often,
photos of you turn into memes.
[ Laughter ]
-With or without mittens,
right?
-This one, you actually proved
that the mittens --
you don't need the mittens
to be a meme.
Everybody was putting too much
on the mittens.
You can do it all on your own.
This was in August --
and it was you sitting
on the Capitol steps,
and somebody memed you there.
[ Laughter ]
Have you reached the point
now where --
Do you have any awareness,
in the moment, of, "Oh,
I'm gonna get memed again"?
[ Laughter ]
-What that was really about is,
it was an all-night session
of the Senate.
Wearing a mask
for like 14 hours,
uh, 18 million amendments.
So there you are -- getting
some fresh air and sunshine.
-Getting some fresh air.
So I want to talk about
the Inflation Reduction Act,
which is really
an incredible accomplishment,
considering it's a 50/50 Senate.
Certainly very high hurdles to
overcome to get anything passed.
Yet it did come up
a little short,
or maybe a lot short,
of what you wanted.
-I would say, a lot short.
-Okay.
So, do you think it's enough
for Democrats to run on
in the midterms or do you --
-No.
-Okay.
-No, I don't.
Look, what we don't talk about
in Congress,
and we don't talk about
in the media,
is what's going on with working
families in this country.
And the truth is that
the middle class of this country
is falling
further and further behind.
Wages are not keeping up
with inflation.
You got over 70 million people
who have no health insurance,
or they're underinsured.
You got 600,000 people
who are homeless.
You got people who can't afford
prescription drugs.
Kids can't afford
to go to college.
Kids are leaving school
deeply in debt,
et cetera, et cetera,
not to mention climate change.
So I think what we have got to
be honest about,
with the American people,
say, "Look,
we're in rough shape right now.
This is reality.
And this is what we have to do
to get out of it."
But I think, Seth, being honest
with the American people,
talking about the growing gap
between the very rich
and everybody else --
we got three people in America
own more wealth than the
bottom half of American society.
We got three Wall Street firms
that have assets
of $20 trillion,
major stockholders
in hundreds and hundreds of
companies throughout America.
We got billionaires
buying elections right now.
You're following
what's going on.
So we got to be honest
with the American people
about what's going on,
about who owns and controls
the nation,
and then have the guts
to stand up
to these powerful
special interests
and tell these greedy bastards
they cannot have it all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-During the back-and-forth,
during the amendments,
during all the negotiations
for the Inflation Reduction Act
bill,
did you think to yourself,
"If we just had
two more Senators --"
did you think to yourself, "If
we had just five more Senators,
10 Senators"?
What's the difference?
-Look, what
the president wanted,
what I wanted,
what I think 48 members
of the U.S. Senate --
Democrats -- wanted
is transformational change
in this country.
We wanted to make at least
community-college tuition-free.
We wanted to expand Medicare.
You know, there are millions of
elderly people in this country
can't afford to go
to a dentist,
can't afford hearing aids,
can't afford eyeglasses.
We wanted to go a lot further
than the Inflation Reduction Act
in transforming
our energy system
away from fossil fuel.
We wanted to deal with the
dysfunctionality of childcare,
make pre-K free
for working families
in this country.
Wanted to build
millions of units
of affordable housing,
putting people to work
doing all of that.
In other words,
what we wanted to do, Seth,
is finally tell
the American people
that their government worked
for them
and not just billionaires.
We were two votes shy,
and I think those two
votes are going to hurt us
a whole lot.
-And now, obviously, you have
an election coming up.
Is it a lot harder to make an
argument going into an election
that, "If you just
give us two more,
we'll make a difference,"
than it would have been
if you had passed a more
robust...?
-I think it will be harder,
but I think what the message
has got to be is,
"We understand.
We feel the pain
that working families
are currently experiencing,
that elderly people
are experiencing.
Give us the Senate plus two.
Give us two more,
and we are prepared
to take on the powerful
special interests right now
who currently dominate
what goes on in Congress."
-It must be frustrating
for someone like you,
that has a real understanding of
the minutiae of the economy,
how it affects so many people,
and yet you must also appreciate
that you're at the mercy,
come election day,
or we might be at the mercy,
of what the gas prices are
that day,
that not every American looks
at the stock-market ticker
every day,
but most of them drive by
and they see a number.
-Right.
-And that number
indicates something.
-That's right.
You're absolutely right.
And yet what
we should understand is
that while gas prices
have soared --
they have gone down
considerably --
the oil companies are making
record-breaking profits.
When people go
to the supermarket
and see the high price of food,
understand that you got
a handful of food companies
that control the industry,
that are also making
record-breaking profits.
So I think what
we have to deal with is
this issue of corporate greed,
of billionaire control
of our political system,
of concentration of ownership,
and we've got to tell
the American people
that we're going to fight.
And it's not gonna happen
tomorrow,
but the fight has got to be
for a government that works
for all of us
and not just
for the people on top.
And I'll tell you something,
Seth.
If we are not successful
in doing that,
you're going to see
more and more people saying,
"I don't believe in democracy.
Why are you telling me
about government?
You give me 30-second
stupid ad on TV,
and yet I can't afford
to send my kid to college,
I can't afford rent,
I can't afford to buy a house.
Don't tell me
about that crap anymore.
I want a strong man
who's gonna get things right,
get the trains to run on time."
And you see that in Italy
recently.
So, you know, this is
not just an economic issue.
It's a political issue, and
that we can lose our democracy
unless you have a government
that stands with
the working class
of this country
and not just
wealthy campaign contributors.
-You obviously wanted, again --
I think this is going to be
a theme of this interview --
You wanted more, you know,
debt forgiveness
on student loans.
-Yeah.
-We did get --
or it should be said,
it was passed -- about $20,000.
-Yeah, not insignificant,
and I applaud the president
for doing that.
-I think a lot of people
talked about what
the political implications
of that are,
how it can be framed.
You, I think,
maybe more than anybody else,
appreciate
exactly what it means
for those people
who had that money forgiven.
How does it change the life
of somebody
to have $20,000 forgiven?
-Seth, I was in Philadelphia
maybe a month ago.
I met with a bunch of people,
including many, many nurses.
We have a desperate need
for more nurses in this country,
and yet these nurses
graduated college
deeply, deeply in debt.
And this nurse got up there and
said, "Bernie, we are not --
my family, my husband and I,
we are not having kids now
because of student debt.
We can't buy a house,
because every month,
we're paying off this outrageous
level of student debt."
So, you have millions and
millions of people
who are unable to go out
and live their lives,
because they
"committed the crime"
of getting an education.
I mean, how crazy is that?
You want people
to get a good education, right?
We're not going to have
a strong country
unless we have a
well-educated workforce.
And yet people have to go
$50,000, $100,000 in debt.
You want to go to
medical school, dental school,
we're talking about
$300,000, $400,000 in debt.
How crazy is that?
I mean, that is why,
in my view -- and I think the
American people support it --
we must make public colleges and
universities tuition-free
so that people don't
leave school deeply in debt,
so that we can have
working-class and
lower-income kids
be able to go to college
without worrying about
having to pay off their debt
you know, for the next 50 years
of their lives.
-I think that's
an excellent point,
and I'm glad you continue
to bang the drum on that.
And I have a lot more
to ask you about.
We'll be right back with more
from Senator Bernie Sanders
right after this.
[ Cheers and applause ]